okay this you really have to see on fox
and friends yesterday morning their
one of their three hosts brian kilmeade
was reduced to arguing with children
about trump versus biden
in a segment that if he was able to feel
shame
he should be completely humiliated by
his participation in this segment an 11
year old kid
pretty accurately makes the case that
he's feeling better
about getting back to school and about
handling the pandemic
now that joe biden is president and is
dealing with the coronavirus in a
serious way
completely reasonable position it's an
11 year old kid kill mead
sort of seems to crack he didn't like
the kid's comment i guess
and he sort of like responds rudely to
the kid it's very weird take a look at
this
how close are you to getting back in the
room what do you miss most about not
being in school
um i miss most obviously seeing my
friends
and all the after school activities that
i've done and i think that
we're very very close getting back to
school and
i think that um the way that
our new president is handling things is
a very good way and we would not have
gone
to this if it were still the last
president
really that's hard to believe because
the last president was saying i want
every kid back in school
uh so lily for you what is your hope
knowing the numbers are going down and
the governor might be opening up
did you notice that kill mead even moved
on to the next kid right away
before the 11 year old could refute
kilmeade's completely flaccid
counterpoint he doesn't want the kid to
say another word
now a source at fox news told me after
the interview kilmeade referred to the
kid as a poopy head
and that seems on brand with the way
this entire segment went
who thought this was a good idea who who
conceives of this segment and thinks
it's a good idea
and if it wasn't killmede and the
segment was put in front of him
why not react by saying interesting it's
so great that you're involved in
following what's going on can can brian
kilmeade
feel anything but complete and total
shame over this segment or at least
should he who wants to bet that this
kid's parents
end up getting threats as a result of
this segment that's the serious thing
and unfortunately uh it wouldn't be
even remotely surprising to me and again
why even try to counter what an 11 year
old is saying
if you strongly refute a kid you're
beating an 11 year old in a debate
and of course if the kid makes more
sense than you which was actually the
case here
you really look like a [ __ ] and it's
almost like that game
show are you smarter than a fifth grader
or a sixth grade or whatever
it's the fox news edition of that game
show and the hosts are losing badly
like imagine feeling the urge to debate
and disprove
rather than encourage a kid for their
involvement in what's going on in the
world around them
and this is how propaganda motivates
people to behave
every differing opinion it doesn't
matter how minor
it doesn't matter how non-threatening
the purveyor of the opinion is it is
perceived as a threat
that must be dealt with immediately you
know interesting
thanks for sharing your opinion it's
great to see kids involved in their
country taking an interest
great no no instead killmead argues
and then argues with and then cuts off
an 11 year old kid
now i'm being totally serious here this
is not i'm not joking about this
if you replaced killmeade with this 11
year old
on fox and friends it would be a way
better and more interesting show i might
become a regular viewer of fox and
friends if
this kid was mixing it up with steve
ducey and ainsley earhart instead of
brian kilmeade
that would make it a better show and i'm
not kidding when i say
the kid seems better informed than most
of the fox news audience i have no doubt
whatsoever about that
now for a moment let's deal with the
substance of brian kilmeed's rebuttal
kilmeade is right
trump said open every school and put
every kid back in school
it was the middle of a pandemic we had
not nearly enough testing
no guidelines about how to safely open
schools absent vaccination and we had no
vaccines we had no precautions we had no
preventative measures trump just said
open it all up it's true trump said it
but it would have been insanely
dangerous to open schools when and how
donald trump said he wanted to do it
and fortunately it didn't happen now joe
biden is doing it
and it's being done safely and it's
abundantly clear
who got the right side of that argument
it wasn't killmead it was the 11 year
old kid
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still
open to stay afloat but covet rescue
fund is one of the few organizations
working to help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to 100
000 for these owners to create
new businesses i would implore anyone in
my audience to help covet rescue fund in
their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video